hales of guys my name is a cherno and
welcome to co dr. chanoor calm code at
the trainer calm is a new website that
have just launched which is exactly what
it sounds like basically a large code
repository for all of the different
series on this channel you're not just
getting downloads to every episode
source code however every piece of
source code you download contains
numerous comments and annotations which
explain everything that goes on in the
code sort of like a book you'll see this
later on in the video firstly you need
to be a member of the channel calm to
access this site most of you probably
are already so you can just go ahead and
log in if you're not you can register by
registering at the channel calm or
simply clicking the register link on
Cody channel calm
fill in all your details and click
create account don't forget to check
your email for an activation link upon
registering once you've registered you
can log into code of the channel calm by
filling in your username and password
and click login
code dr. Chadwick on
y'see to be a premium member Premium
Membership currently costs to 850
australian dollars around eight US
dollars per month the reason it's
monthly is because I'll be updating it
constantly with more and more code
including any new series i create every
time an episode gets released code gets
uploaded make sure you read the Terms of
Service first before you get a premium
membership since you'll have to agree to
those terms in a nutshell you're allowed
to do whatever you like with the code if
you follow two conditions firstly you
have to remove all the comments found in
the code that are written by myself and
you have to change the code enough so
that it constitutes fair use accept the
terms and click the get premium button
to be taken to paypal currently the
payment is non-recurring which means
that you have to buy premium every month
yourself so don't worry about having to
cancel your subscription later you're
only buying one month once you fill in
your details and confirm the payment
you'll be taken back to code of the term
calm and this time you'll see the proper
home page I've written a short post on
how to use a site so go ahead and read
that you'll find all the basic links on
the top of the page the left containing
different series and the right
containing your account and the logout
button clicking in a series will take
you to its appropriate page there you'll
find a description of the series and
every single episode individually
currently I've done the first hundred
episodes of game programming but don't
worry the rest are coming soon click on
any episode and you'll get a zip file
downloaded with source code more on that
later 3d game programming source code
will be released soon as well as all the
other series clicking on your username
and top right of the page will display
your account information including how
many days of premium you still have left
logout will obviously lock you out now
remember how we downloaded episode 56
let's check that out inside the zip
folder you'll find the source code to
the relevant episode if you like you can
simply read through it there's quite a
lot of content let's open game to Java
and take a look
some comments contain numbers and
brackets that refers the changes that
were made and in which episode the
download also contains all the resources
you delight in the episode including
this awesome level file and all the
other sprites
let's check out another way you can use
the code inside Eclipse every download
is eclipse ready meaning opening it is a
breeze just copy the episodes folder
navigate to your Eclipse workspace and
paste a folder
then open eclipse create a new Java
project and type in the exact name of
the folder in this case episode 56 then
click finish and you're done to run the
game open the main class which is gambit
Java
and then click either the debug or Run
button that's it episode 56 had a nice
cliffhanger see if you can solve it
anyway that's Cody Journell calm I hope
you guys get heaps of use out of it I'll
see you all on Friday with the premiere
of the flappy bird opengl series source
code for that will of course be
available on courage of the chinotto com
goodbye I want one more thing the first
20 people who get premium get a fifty
percent discount mini 425 for 30 days
hurry